some of you haven't thought about this
for your tender little precious
snowflakes work junior needs to plan on
working now and while he's in school I
work 40 to 60 hours a week and got out
in four years so shut up I don't want to
hear it and most of you that are
listening to me worked when you went to
college this idea that you can be a
snowflake and just hang out over there
and play beer pong in between classes is
nut Oh
now if you've got the money to send your
kids to college and they don't and they
don't work that's okay
I didn't make all of mine work I had the
money to pay for it though but you don't
sit over there play beer pong and take
out student loans because you didn't
have any money it's because you weren't
working Junior
work work work work work work work a lot
and don't work at some job just flopping
whoppers okay wiper floppers don't make
any money we're not talking about
minimum wage job go make some money man
I mean you make some good money cutting
grass walking dogs nanny babysitting
fancy word for it nanny right I mean you
can you can make some decent bucks ten
twelve fifteen bucks an hour if you'll
start watching what you're doing and you
can pour it on and do some gentle
self-employed idea some of you are
pretty good with websites and that kind
of stuff I know one kid making pretty
good money just doing SEO and he's a
junior in college and search engine
optimization for those of you don't know
what that means so I mean yeah there's
all kinds of stuff you can do I don't
care what you do but work pick out a
school you can afford and apply for
40,000 scholarships at least a thousand
minimum oh and by the way junior can
work now while he's in high school start
saving up money why or college start
working for college now how you get to
go that's a real strong possibility
these things all happen but the last one
is less important but I'm going to in
order these all work by far the biggest
one is college selection but the last
one is make sure he's getting really
good scores on his a CTE or SAT
whichever direction he's going
and if he takes a test go take a go pay
for a tutor and send even to a tutor and
then retake the test all three of my
kids did that and all three of my kids
every time they retook the test got a
better grade each time in our case on
the AC T their scores went up every time
they took the test tutor then retook and
that helps a lot in the scholarship
world and when you fill out five son
stuff like that understand financial aid
to those people because those people are
stupid is a student loan and a student
loan is not financial aid a student loan
is financial bondage financial aid is
someone pays for something you want to
pay them back that's called a
scholarship or a grant but a student
loan is not financial aid a student loan
is debt you're going to have to pay it
later so don't do that so seriously moms
and dads you there's something about our
kids physically looking like adults that
we think mentally and emotionally
they're ready to make big huge multi
hundred thousand dollar decisions by
themselves and they're just not if
you're 18 and you can make all those
decisions by yourself I got to tell you
you're an unusual human being are you
mature for 18 great but you still need
your mom and dad's guidance and so mom
and dad love them enough to parent them
with firmness on college selection work
taking the a CT degree field selection
and scholarships applying applying
applying applying for scholarships to
the point that you hear a lot of teenage
whining because they're doing all of
these things then your kid can go to
school without any debt when mama is
broke there you go worst case scenario
join the military you can go without any
debt it's a decision you got to decide
that's how you can do it so all of those
things are possible National dollars
I'll play a bunch you want to
that it's very very possible to go to
school that free but it's a decision hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]